the block lock him down the block can
you just tell me once to worry about you
guys going into bed-stuy
to make this movie and what was the
first reaction to everybody in bed-stuy
when y'all said we gonna make this movie
how did you have how'd you guys roll I
mean I knows it's what but how did you
guys handle that going in the block that
we shot on in bed-stuy was in a
neighborhood that was them was a
depressed neighborhood a lot of you know
the ills that plague a lot of urban
communities around the country you know
drugs crime etcetera etcetera but at the
same time everybody in the neighborhood
knew who spitefully was by then had seen
the previous films and for the most part
I think we're pretty excited about his
painting except for the drug dealers and
so you know spike has always supported
the community and this was another way
to do that and of course his office was
also in Brooklyn and but we also had
security concerns but we didn't want to
you know bring policemen for the
neighborhood etcetera so what we did was
we hired a contingent of the fruit of
Islam who did the security force on the
film which is usually done by police and
off-duty cops and that sort of thing
interesting thing was none of these guys
were ever armed they just stood around
in their suits and bowties
soompi stars - and so bean pie but
during the entire time we were in that
neighborhood through all the
pre-production the construction and set
dressing and all that through the
shooting period there were no incidents
whatsoever the community's respect for
the fruit of Islam was such that they
didn't have to do anything all they had
to do was be present
you guys didn't you guys also have life
before he started a black party yes yes
but I will say that I do recall one
incident on the set where I think
somebody pulled a knife or something and
there was one incident and it lasted
about half a second before the guy was
disarmed by the fruit of Islam who then
said to him brother you need to go you
know home so that's what happened but
anyway so that's what I remember most
and it was I think after a while I think
the neighborhood got used to us and it
was glad we were there when Thomas was
not here is another one we should really
talk about because their people weren't
here atiast history is that the team
which we started working together and
she's gonna have it and we ran off with
many more films after that myself
directing my class mate and why you
graduate film school the great scimitar
ernest dickerson
the great costume designer Ruth Carter
Ruth
Robbie and antenna and rate doll
celebrate they were all the classmates
they're all classmates at Hampton
Institute
so I'm Morehouse Ernest Howard and we
had three beautiful black woman from
Hampton went Thomas the great production
designer we all had a charge to how can
we use our skills to show this is the
hottest day of summer so when wind read
the script I said when this takes place
on one block so what was what we had to
do was we'll get the final block and
bed-stuy had to empty lots facing each
other because we had to build Sony's
Korean Korean fruit and vegetable stand
and then directly opposite we had to we
had to build Sal's famous pizzeria so it
took him a while to find that block and
but the whole film is shot in one block
and you know going back to the block a
lot the last week or so for this 25th
anniversary everybody comes back I was
there with Daniel the other day said man
I know this block is small but it's not
really a big block and so there was
various we need a lot of needed other
vacancies on the block too so we could
build the radio station Samuel Jackson
mrs. mrs. your love daddy Ruby Dee but
that was somebody lived in that house
but at the also we need to have a block
that had very little trees because we
don't want him able to hide under the
shade and we wanted the chart Oh Ernest
cameraman camera person Ruth costumes
and when Thomas I said we're shooting
this film in the summer it's on the
hottest day this summer is going to come
up and
summer summer 1989 and we when if Duncan
was out of people washing watching the
film and then in the air-conditioned
theaters want people to sweat and now
and then and we did that how do we do
that
her life will put butane torch is under
the lens remember the wall with the with
the cornermen the great late great Robin
Harris we painted that wall red it
wasn't like that
and then Ruth with her with the very
colorful costumes all that all that
stuff was meant to convey that it takes
place - date of summer